este problema dice resta 2 menos tres y
menos 6 18 y lo primero que me gustaría
hacer es deshacerme de este signo menos
por lo tanto voy a distribuirlo sobre
este paréntesis otra forma de pensarlo
es que voy a multiplicar menos 1 por
toda esta expresión entonces vamos a
hacer eso la primera la primera parte es
dos menos tres y esa la voy a dejar
igualita 2 - 3 y y ahora si este menos
lo distribuyó y me queda menos 6 menos 6
y luego menos por menos 18 y es más 18 y
menos por menos es más nos queda más 18
y muy bien entonces ya no tenemos
paréntesis ya no hay un signo menos
afuera ya podemos concentrarnos en sumar
estos números complejos juntando las
partes reales y las partes imaginarias
las partes reales son dos son dos porque
no tiene y y menos seis entonces tenemos
dos y menos seis y las partes complejas
serían menos tres y degenerar a este
color azul serían menos 3
y 18 y entonces vamos a sumar esas
partes correspondientes 26 es menos 4
nos quedaría menos 4 de parte real y
luego tenemos que hacer menos 3 y más 18
y menos 3 de algo más 18 de ese otro
algo es igual a 15 o bien otra forma de
pensar es que si a 18 de algo le
quitamos 3ds algo nos queda 15 entonces
vaya a la respuesta aquí es más 15 y ese
algo que estamos tomando es la unidad
imaginaria y muy bien entonces la
respuesta es menos 4 más